allez réveille-toi réveille-toi je te
dis
bienvenue que coranzaï on t'attendait
avec impatience
c'est un château oui tu as l'immense
privilège d'être invité dans ce lieu
incroyable ce sera l'occasion de faire
un vœu un vœu qui sera exaucé quel qu'il
soit notre vœu sera exaucé appelez-moi
la reine j'aimerais savoir sur quels
critères on a été choisi un seul feu il
n'y a qu'un vœu que j'aimerais exaucer
si votre vœu est vraiment sincère il
sera exaucé vous devrez chercher et
trouver la clé qui est caché quelque
part dans le château
mais j'ai oublié de vous préciser un
détail qui a son importance
une fois que vous aurez trouvé la clé et
que le vœu aura été exaucé vos souvenirs
s'effaceront et vous oublierez à tout
jamais ce château oh mais comment ça
je vais vous dire je sais qu'aucun de
nous ne va en cours je le sais très bien
c'est trop moche pour lui plaire
on pourrait peut-être en profiter pour
s'entraider se soutenir
[Musique]
notre rencontre
c'est pas le fruit du hasard un toit de
décider comment tu veux utiliser cette
clé la décision t'appartient
pourquoi pourquoi
je dirais bien tu n'es pas seul qu'au
courant
[Musique]
on peut se retrouver on y arrivera mais
il faut vivre
[Musique]
merci
adieu